jokes to tell it's too early Horning
I've been here about 10 times every time
I come I fall off this side right here
tell about a little thing right here
that lounges walk and talk and I feel
like I've lost that about there we go
okay so we're going to be doing
optimization this morning we're going to
be doing theories it's a theory talk for
hearing people I guess I can tell the
anecdote that I went to China in
December and I gave something like this
talk a bunch of kind of theory stuff to
big audiences Canada China nowadays
machine learning is really really
popular so like literally audiences of
3,000 people and the end of it all these
kind of theoretical concepts you know
they kind of nodded quietly but everyone
raised their hand said what do you think
about deep learning I think I'll start
your talk by saying here's what I think
about defending it's important to be
empirical and try things out and do it
at scale in learn phenomena and so I was
around in the 80s when that was all
everyone did that was the early machine
I'm very very empirical and of course
there was this kind of covering number
of people that you know proved some semi
relevant theories but it was mostly
empirical I think that's really great
but you know my own career I just wanted
to kind of do something a little more
mathematical turn over the next
generations something a little more
mathematical so slowly helped it move
the field net direction in it you know
many of us have done that it really
worked but now the field has gone way
back to thin all of the swung back it's
extremely imperative so many talk about
you learning in the outside world that's
what you need it holds a miracle real
net stuff and again that's great I think
it's changing world but for the young
people the room there's a whole other
world of theory and I think so I'm going
to go ahead and move to my second slide
here here's one way of animating these
issues is that if you really look at the
amount of platforms we're working on
they're distributed they're parallel
they're asynchronous they're complicated
in all kinds of ways and so kind of
classical results for single processor
you know synchronous
cetera breakdown of the sex there's all
kinds of brand new theory problems and
they really matter because you don't do
this kind of stuff right worry about
communication worry about asynchrony or
get the items that are wrong and
surprisingly slow won't break in various
ways so there's just all kinds of really
good challenges here this is kind of a
part of this is the optimization sign of
course there's also the kind of a
statistics side of analyzing things and
so today just focus on optimization but
courses all of those so I decided to
kind of pick a few themes that tell
little stories my group is now really
focused on optimization because I do
think that there's it's an era where you
can really do fundamental theory if you
look around for lower bounds and
statistics and computer science there's
not that many of them out there
computer science doesn't have very many
success for but they've kind of done in
a very classical setting so there's a
lot of opportunity to kind of figure out
lower bounds when you think about
optimization because optimization has
the auricle over vents and there's kind
of a classical set of them that are
intriguing and interesting but also very
limited so there's a lot of room oh but
now to kind of think about lower bounds
so there's a little bit of that in this
talk and that's what a lot of my group
is interested in these days so here's an
outline of just some of the topics I've
picked a couple my co-authors are in the
room you may be able to help me is about
going to continuous-time so I think this
is actually critical almost all of our
theory work has been done in discrete
time and algorithmic time and you don't
see a lot of the phenomena in a clean
crisp way at discrete time you can see
the much more cleanly in continuous time
so I'm going to focus on that a bit
that's just kind of getting started
eyeliner research particularly word
symplectic is important there's a lot to
be there a little bit about saddle
points because if you do want to get out
of the convex world you have to think
about saddle points and you have to
think about how to avoid them
efficiently in high dimensions
then Levi's is the room I work with Lila
on something called stochastic lis
controlled stochastic gradient sapphire
to use stochastic radius it but remain
efficient just kind of outlined the
search five years now and I may or may
not get to some of these other things
the last one I knew kind of I'd be
hopefully on board this is less Theory
oriented but talking about some
collaborations with systems people and I
think this is really a fantastic venue
for collaboration but she already has
often we thought as an AI kind of
collaborations had AI but stat mesh
systems is Julia River I've been doing
that for about ten years now I want to
report a kind of about latest work there
so let me start with this variational
Hamilton's inflected work this is work
largely with andre-louis Oda Eiichiro
sitting for students here or what were
students here honors moved on to
Wisconsin and then Mike Betancourt has
joined us in this last little wave of
this activity as we started to think
about selecting integration okay so this
is an attempt to talk about an S drop
acceleration in a different way try to
get some new front flip to the topic
that's like alright so let's just set up
some notation here this part of the talk
is gonna be convex optimization
unconstrained so all of us know what our
friend classical gradient descent is
this is going to be non stochastic this
part of talk we're just going to talk
about gradients and being flow so it's
really all know in this general setting
just smooth but not strongly convex we
get convergence rates of the form 1 over
K that means after I've seen K gradients
my hair is within 1 over K up optimum
and that was no one I don't know for 300
years or something roughly but kind of
it came out as a general theory just in
the last three or 40 years and then at
some point someone asks are there lower
balance that one can talk about is this
the best you can do
well what do you mean the best you can
do a convex function there's a single
optimum somehow if you just look at the
thing you could find it if you are
allowed to have a higher a Taylor
expansion you can just solve for it and
so on
so the numerous youth in perspective
which emerged sir 70s 80s and others in
most of the Russian school define a
notion of Oracle and there are many
different kinds of Oracle - one of them
was that you can look only at great
against you're allowed to us access the
function value of the great anywhere you
want your arguments constrained in some
way so maybe it can only take its new
step in or if you can access gradients
in the span of all the waiting's you've
seen some come some a shoot spraying on
computational power this so it's not a
kind of possible computer science
constraint it's not kind of the Torian
spirit right since its own thing and so
under it constraints like that you can
get lower bounds and they were turned
out to be one over K squared they're
faster than gradient descent and this is
kind of surprise to people in any or
I've a glee remember some of this you
know great descent seemed optimal if
you're just allowed to only look at
gradients and have a fairly strong
constraint catch look at it a gradient
everywhere so you know it is thinking
the steepest descent direction and even
if we give ourselves an Oracle to tell
us how far to move it's still suboptimal
so it was a surprise that there was an
algorithm this simple that came along
that had a faster rate than gradient
descent
this is that's drug acceleration and one
of the anyways to express it so it has
now two sequences on just one and one of
the sequences the y-value basically does
a gradient steps using the x values and
then the next x value is a convex
combination of the last two Y values so
many people stare at this and try to
think about their own perspective on and
explain it there are many interesting
explanations of it one thing that I
think many of us have noticed looking at
this is some point is that this this is
important here there's a YK plus one
here so this kind of looks like a
classical kind of explicit step very
shadows looks like an implicit step and
if you know anything about the
combination of explicit implicit that's
like the leapfrog integrator oops I
forgot to put this on I told you I'd do
it
that can start again sorry to all you
out there now I've just woken up anyway
so it's gonna be a better talk from here
on
okay so there's Nesterov acceleration
and leapfrog integrator looks kind of
like a leapfrog integrator if you know
anything my group most people do
optimization don't think about
integration very much
so we're hawai in the world would this
be an integration integration of what ok
so that's part of the purpose of the
first part of talk to relate
optimization and integration so in fact
if you're Bayesian frequentist that's
kind of nice to know that those things
can be more closely linked because the
frequent just mostly do optimization
kind of things in the Bayesian mostly
they do integration and they're actually
more close than you might think
that's the part that's one of the points
of this part of the talk ok so just
again the kind of history was there was
all of these gradient methods including
things like Mehra descent cubic
regularize Newton and so on that were
being studied rates were being achieved
for those and then Oracle method models
were set up and the Oracle models were
typically had a better rate than the
gradient based or the higher gradient
based methods and so you could
accelerate sort of all these things and
so there was a whole line of research
there's to this day of accelerating
these things oops
and how did you do this well there
wasn't really kind of a just a
generative mechanism for taking the
Nesterov idea just sort of applying it
to an algorithm and accelerating it
mostly is you kind of look at the
algebra and you learn nestra style and
you kind of do similar algebra and
problem after problem that's what people
did and derivations are sort of a few
pages typically there's kind of estimate
sequence technique but it's really more
about analysis than about generating
algorithms all right but nonetheless
this has gone on and there's just very
many important real-world applications
of this acceleration idea interestingly
intriguingly these are not descent
methods so they will go down and then it
will come back up
that seems suboptimal but it's not it's
counterintuitive Lee and sort of the
intuition is that if you're going to
kind of go really fast down the road
you kind of take the curves pretty quick
and it's a little sloshing is going to
be needed and allow and in fact needed
ok so
so let's move into the continuous-time
world right away so rainy descent is the
disk organization of what's called
gradient flow in mathematics there are
huge textbooks on gradient flow it's an
old area still active to this day so
it's a differential equation there's no
step size I just write down the
differential equation and if you want to
solve it on a computer you have to
integrate it with an integrator so you
could use something like runge-kutta or
whatever and you'll start to introduce
things like step sizes but the
differential equation has no notion of a
step size so there was a very nice paper
that we saw came out in 2014 from
Stanford sue Boyd and Candace or they
took Nesterov acceleration those two
equations I showed you and they took the
step size analytically to 0 and took
those difference equations and turn them
into a differential equation and here's
the one that here's what popped out it
was a second-order differential equation
it was non-homogeneous there was an
interesting factor of three there and
that is a no de that you cannot solve
but you can numerically solve there's
Bessel functions that allow you to sort
of understand this solution and the
Bessel functions have oscillations so
they could study these oscillations and
sort of understand them a little bit
from the point of view of kind of
applied OTE research so that was pretty
interesting you know but looking at that
sort of you know are that you had you
asked the question why that differential
equation what's special about that why
would you have ever written that down or
what's the principle that delivered it
all right in a particular if you're
trying to think about this notion of
achieving an Oracle rate the Oracle rate
and somehow the best you can do so there
must be a principle that says it's best
for a particular some particular
algorithm is best for some reason so
what we're really asking for in this
field I think is what's the best way to
optimize what's the optimal way to
optimize all right so I don't think
we've ever really stated that as clear
as we should but that's really what
we're asking for so if you write down a
way to optimize in continuous time you
have to say kind of why that's best it's
not just enough to write down a
differential equation and in discrete
time similar story you got to write down
a difference equation for some reason
okay so um
that God has started thinking about that
is there a deeper general generative
mechanism that generates this and then
maybe some other you know accelerated
looking Oh des for other areas that are
you know discretized in some way so
we're going to start by talking about a
variational approach to acceleration and
then the key of this is actually not
that so much this isn't not in some
sense not that hard the key is the is
actually the discretization and if you
know any like real physics about how you
take like differential equations of the
cosmos or our proteins those are
differential equations how you
discretize is the whole the key right if
you discuss in the wrong way you lose
things like conservation of momentum
conservation meters you don't do the
right physics you have to describes in
the right way to actually do real
science so I think that our field needs
will will I think it'll be useful for us
to take on that point of view okay so
I'm just gonna jump right to it so what
is variational mean so first of all you
know it's a whole area of mathematics
and what it really means is that you
take some problem of some kind algebraic
or geometric or whatever and turn it
into an optimization problem
that's what variational really means so
eigen values right how do you define an
eigen value well ax equals lambda X oh
that's an algebraic definition there's
another way which is write down a rated
coefficient and you optimize you've
turned it into an optimization problem
the eigenvalue is the maximum you know
maximum over a ratio and there's lots of
other problems where you took it
something didn't look like optimization
turn into an authorization problem why
well there's now a whole slew of
numerical methods analytical techniques
that apply but most importantly you can
start to approximate now you can say
well the original solution can be
written as this optimization problem I
can perturb the optimization problem and
maybe topologically I haven't perturbed
the solution too much and then perturb
problems easier to solve okay so that's
the whole spirit of variational ideas
and you know finite element methods is
you know K is that a variational
methodology and so on all right so the
word of course comes from calculus of
variations and you know the first user
of that was lagron the differential
equations of Newtonian mechanics like F
equals MA and said is there a generative
principle for those differential
equations you know I don't know Newton
invented them but is there a better
underlying principle and so he says yeah
there was there's this object called a
Lagrangian which instead of writing our
differential equation I write
something that I integrate guidances the
flipside of the duality of calculus and
now you optimize that integral and
that's the Lagrangian perspective on
dynamics and then Hamilton kind of
refined it and then it turned into the
main tool in the last century for
physics not the Newtonian point of view
all right so here's going to be our
Lagrangian L agrandi and is just a
function of paths so X is a continuous
time path X dot is its derivative and
these are going to be non-homogeneous so
I put time in there and the first term
here is a Bregman divergence and the
second term is the function we're trying
to optimize and all those little E's are
just scaling functions to give us a
variety of algorithms going to give us
some degrees of freedom okay so here's
our friend the Bregman divergence right
here you all know what it is I want to
measure the distance between x and y I
could do that with an auxiliary function
H take the discrepancy between the
linear approximation and X and the
actual value at y that distance there is
the distance between x and y on this
axis measured with this auxiliary
function that is the Bregman divergence
if H is quadratic this is just another
way of defining Euclidean distance
between x and y all right so what we're
going to what we're doing here is
putting bregman divergence in as this
first term of this thing to be optimized
okay so I'll tell you how optimize it in
a minute it's interesting bregman
divergence it takes where you are right
now and it takes where you are plus a
little bit of velocity all right so it's
kind of like a you know stretching in
some directions kind of energy term all
right again these are just a time
scalings forget about that this is the
key part X plus Delta X all right so
think of that kind of like a kinetic
energy and think of this as a potential
energy in fact forgetting that this is
just kind of the function you're trying
to go downhill on so it should be your
potential you want to go down if you
actually plug in H being quadratic and
suppose H is quadratic then that regular
version simplify just exactly the
kinetic energy so if you're businesses
you say okay that really looks like a
classical Lagrangian from physics
kinetic energy minus potential energy
all right now we have three of these
time scaling functions that have been
put in just to give maximal
flexibility to this Lagrangian but if
you want to get optimal rates from this
thing it turns out there's only really
one degree of freedom the alphas betas
and gammas are related by what we call
the ideal skating conditions so if you
set alpha that's going to determine beta
and gamma and if you set beta that's
going to terminate alpha and gamma as
well so I'll get into that a little bit
more but let's just assume there's one
degree of freedom okay here's our again
our bregman Lagrangian now what do you
do with lagrangian's well you do
calculus of variations so you stick the
Lagrangian as a function of paths into
an integral you integrate this as a
function of time and then you minimize
over path so you pick the path which
minimizes what's called the action in
physics little Ranjan all right so we've
now got ourselves an optimization
problem we can solve this in many
different ways maybe numerically or
whatever right but the first thing to do
is to get necessary and sufficient
conditions for an optimum or at least
sufficient conditions so you get that by
in essence taking the partial
derivatives and set them all to zero
that's what you do in discrete spaces
and continuous spaces that's called the
Euler Lagrange equations and it's just a
differential equation okay so it sort of
takes a bunch of partial derivatives of
L with respect to its two arguments and
this is now a function of time you take
its total time derivative and you can
easily do that you can just hit this
thing with derivatives and out it's
going to pop a just an Eau de a
differential equation alright so let's
just do that
here is the differential equation the
results so let's call that the master Oh
de I claim this is going to generate
essentially all known very accelerated
gradient methods in continuous-time all
right so this master is worth looking at
for a moment it's second-order it is
non-homogeneous it's got some geometry
here this H is going to give us
different geometries if we're working on
manifolds we would get different H's and
then we have you know lo and behold the
gradient of the function we want to go
downhill on so it looks like kind of a
damped oscillator sort of setting for
minimizing F which that's pretty natural
okay so let's now try to get some more
insight of this first of all
we can get a rate in continuous time if
you were to solve this thing in
continuous time you would approach the
optimum at a certain rate in continuous
time and then here we get a little sense
that we're on the right path here with
this methodology because the getting the
rate is actually one line proof yeah it
does that we've neglected the one
endpoint is going to be the optimum the
other endpoint is an arbitrary starting
point and so you get the same yes
there'll be there's an initial in its
initial condition problem it's not a two
point boundary problem and the Hessian
is evaluated at a different point then
then XT yeah that's right it's evaluated
at this sort of forward point but still
a well-defined differential equation and
that's really critical to get this
acceleration notion if you've added just
an XT it wouldn't have accelerated yeah
so is each like given to you as part of
the constraints the problem is no it's
you're a designer of the algorithm you
choose H so I maybe tell you what
manifold I'm on the Sam on the space of
all semi definite matrices then you
would choose an H which is fitted to
that garage is I kind of want to attach
the first term somehow was like the
consider lambda times the constraints of
the problem because thing that's not how
you should think about that well I'd
like to think of about as a separate
degree of freedom use use the designer
can use I don't have to use the natural
geometry I might want to use a different
one for my own purposes
I mean when we think about it should
forget the geometries just that write
down a lot of HS and try them out you'll
get a whole span of algorithms and some
of them you know can be used for
different problems okay so there's a
one-line proof of convergence here of
this thing so here's the convergence
rate it turns out to be order e to the
minus beta T so that beta T that you
chose it determines the convergence rate
and here's the proof you just simply
write down a Lyapunov function that uses
this bregman divergence all right take
the first derivative of this the time
derivative of this we open up function
here it is right here and ask that the
Lyapunov function be less than or equal
to zero the condition that achieves that
is exactly this right here all right so
that suggests that this is a kind of a
useful way to actually just kind of
collect the dynamics of these
optimization problems in one formalism
and bregman divergence plays a key role
all right but that's not the main story
the main story is something else so
first of all this is wildly ambitious to
suggest that we're able to get
exponentially fast algorithms we know
that we're not able to get that in
general we're able to get these 1 over K
1 over K squared polynomial kinds of
rates we can get exponential rates in
some settings but very you know strong
assumptions are needed so what gives
here so let's assume that we know
already that we can't get exponential
rates so let's be less ambitious and
let's set let's explore what happens
when we set beta to be logarithm of T so
the logarithm will kill the exponential
and let's give ourselves an extra degree
of freedom let's call it P log T so I
can get T squared 1 over T squared 1
over T even higher you know values of
polynomials ok so let's do that let's
set beta equal to P log P this will turn
into 1 over T to the P ok and then alpha
and beta are determine gamma or
determine once I picked that so now the
convergence rate for that choice if we
can achieve it we're going to write down
a differential equation we don't know we
can solve it yet will give us this rate
of convergence ok so we might get it
will get gradient floatie when P is
equal to 1 and we might hopefully get a
span of other interesting items in
continuous time all right so if you plug
that into our master differential
equation you get this differential
equation now
we'll have some geometry and now this is
starting to look a little simpler and in
particular when P is equal to 2 we get
that mysterious 3 they're from sue Boyd
Candace yeah we do not we know that in
these smooth convex problems were not
going to get it all right
if we have uniform convexity we're going
to be able to achieve exponential now so
the barrier in continuous time does not
exist okay a continuous time you can
achieve the x12 right but a continuous
time the notion of rate is actually not
very deep it just means I've changed the
clock so if you're using a certain clock
and I reprise the clock with a
one-to-one function I can go as fast as
I want all right
and in some sense the fact that
acceleration is not a mystery in
continuous time is what allows us to
explain it it's just a change of clock
the mystery then is solved by when you
go back into discrete time something to
break the exponential rates and
continuous time are not achievable in
discrete time whereas the other rates
are achievable in streak time so it's a
theory of discretization where the
acceleration thing starts to get
explained okay so there's our
differential equation and if we start
now setting particular values I already
alluded to P equals 2 with P equals 2 we
get this su Boyden candidates we've
recovered that we also can get the
version of this as well which has this
convergence rate when P is equal to 2 if
we use a different H okay so that's 4 P
equals 2 but we are perfectly happy to
also take higher values of P as well and
we can get you know other kinds of rates
so for example cubic regularize Newton
can be think if we got out of this
framework and then higher values of P is
our entually as well all right so now if
you start looking at the differential
equations for different values of P if
you start looking at different ways over
different ways of P you let's write them
down and see what mathematical structure
is emerging here so here's p equals 2
where we get this convergence rate so
there's the differential equation here's
P equals 3 let's just try it out we get
this convergence rate in continuous time
and here's the difference equation and
you don't have to be an expert in
differential equations to look at this
and see some similarities they're really
the same differential equation just like
three has changed to four four is change
to nine to
changed or three all right and so what's
happening here and this is the first
part it starts to get interesting is
that this Lagrangian has a mathematical
property which is known as covariance
which means is that as I change P I'm
actually getting the exact same path and
continuous time the path is not changing
what's changing is my rate of moving
along the path alright so for P small I
move at a slow rate when I turn up P all
I do is take the same path and move it a
faster rate in continuous time all right
and then the next slide there's a proof
of covariance it's just that it's it's
invariant to repr ammeter ization so
this is true of this class of Lagrange's
it's not true of gradient flow if you re
parameterize the clock and gradient flow
you obtain a different path all right so
that suggests there is an optimal way to
optimize in a sense it's actually the
path which is something interesting
about the path and the fact that speed
you move along it is not the important
part
yeah accelerated obviously is a
different path than the gradient flow
count that's right it's a different flow
in the brainy path yeah when you said
you know these alpha T abilities and
then yeah you sent all of them according
to a single parameter P yeah this will
wait presumably that's right so this is
a particular class of algorithms that
are kind of on the Nesterov nemirovsky
spectrum they're all the gradient based
methods and get something that comes
from ready flow to the acceleration and
figure out what all right wait question
and wait at the other talk we'll talk
about that okay because that's that is
that is really the the key that momentum
and gradient flow both belong in the
same algorithm okay to get the sort of
the I think the ultimate story let's
just focus on the momentum kind of flows
for now and we know gradient flow has
exists and we'll talk about the putting
the together so here's the proof that
this is a covariant operator you just
simply reaper ammeter eyes time if I go
from T to tau T I've just changed my
notion of the clock and I plug that into
my master differential equation all I
can I can recover that by simply a
change of from redefining the parameters
getting alpha tittles and twiddles and
beta twiddles and so on okay so under
this situation these you know sort
instead of assumptions we have an
optimal way to optimize there is a
particular path and acceleration is just
changing the speed at which you move
along it okay so in that sense the
mystery has gone away in continuous time
it's not it's not it's actually trivial
it's not even a mystery at all all right
but now the whole key becomes how do we
discretize to get back to continue to
from just continuous time to discrete
time and stay stable and still retain
the fast rate and discrete time all
right so let's try to discretize that
those differential equations well for
some other second-order and so the
standard way of discretizing is to turn
diminutive to first-order equations to
which you apply say runge-kutta or or
Euler okay so here are the two first
order equations that this part of the
talk there's a bunch of symbols that
just come into the descritization I
don't really want to go through all the
details I just want to give you a flavor
there's nothing particularly you know
hard happening there it's just things
like Euler descritization applied to
these two first order differential
equations when you do that out pops this
particular algorithm right here this is
an algorithm you can put it on the
computer it's Euler descritization that
under my differentiation but it's not
stable all right so here it is just run
it on the computer it sort of seems like
it's doing pretty well so it's derived
in here and it shoots off to infinity
right here it is on one dimension
shooting off to infinity so you would
never want to put this on your computer
and actually propose this as an
algorithm moreover it loses the fast
rate okay so this was a bad
discretization bad idea all right so you
could turn to other things like just
runge-kutta or you don't look at stiff
differential equation methods and all
that and they also don't work they
aren't stable and they lose the fast
rate all right so this point it became a
bit of a conundrum how do you discretize
these differential equations they're
kind of not classically studied there's
not a literature on them seemingly okay
so there's now two paths to our little
research project here one of them is
that we did discover a descritization
method by taking Nesterov equations and
looking at them and reverse engineering
and thinking them as a descritization
methodology for differential equations
that's not how next well thought about
them you can look at them and think of
them that way and turn them into a
discretization of these differential
equations taking his style and applying
them and when you do you get our then we
can
prove is stable and we can prove that it
achieves the fast rate and it's a very
nestra of looking algorithm while it's
not exactly Nesterov so I'll show you
that result all right but the I think
better way to think about that and this
is ongoing research is to remember that
there's this notion of symplectic
integration so I remember this back when
I said MIT I was taking a class on
differential geometry and they talked at
some point about discretizing
differential equations and they gave the
usual long list that I just alluded to
and they said well that's why not people
really do in practice and so one reason
hell what did they do in practice they
said well they do symplectic integration
and so let me just say what that is
before I get into it if you go to a
chemist or a physicist to simulate you
know similar in the cosmos or simulating
a protein and ask them you know how do
you discretize your differential
equations they say well we use
symplectic integration of course and
people spend their whole careers doing
symplectic integrators and symplectic is
a geometric term and what's happening
here is if so I suppose I do a
Hamiltonian and I'm doing something you
know the cosmos so I know that energy is
conserved and momentum is conserved so
I'm on cycles the differential equation
gives me cycles so along that cycle say
energy is being conserved all right so
if I were to try to get that cycle by
discretizing I'm going to get a little
procedure that hops along and of course
it won't be exactly lying on the cycle
all right and you know I'll have steps
so but I could ask the interesting
question about is there a discord
ization that even though it's
approximate exactly conserves energy or
exactly conserves momentum so even
though it's a numerical method now and
I'm getting an approximation at least
the physics is still there I haven't
lost because if otherwise if I simulate
the cosmos for a few from the Big Bang
till now I'm going to be bleeding away
energy and momentum I'm just not doing
the right physics okay
it's not even approximate in a
reasonable sense all right so this was a
problem in the 1800s at Jacobi of
jacobians and Hamilton of hamiltonians
figured out a whole theory for it and
it's called symplectic integration so
they figured out a way to conserve
quantities like energy momentum and so
the right way thing about you go into
phase space you take X and
and that you do Finchel conjugate of
actor the velocity and get the momentum
and now you get X comma P and in that
phase space the differential equations
have a certain reform and along the the
orbits you don't want to just look at
the vector along the orbits you want to
look at a little triple of vectors you
want to look like the little local
Jacobian and that Jacobian as you flow
along should be conserved in volume and
there's a differential geometry a
version of this where you're taking
exterior forms and conserving them as
you go along this sum so it has kind of
a stiffness property that there's a
little local volume conservation along
these things and so these things allow
you to go much faster you can hop much
faster this is well known in physics
like a factor of ten then a classical
discretization and they're much more
stable and so this is all understood
this has been like 150 years there's big
beautiful Springer books about this and
it's a beautiful area of mathematics it
also ties directly hamilton-jacobi those
names may be familiar for other reasons
hamilton-jacobi bellman equations that's
the source of the theory of
reinforcement learning and these
equations are at the root of
reinforcement learning ok so I
remembered some of this and at some
point kind of clicked I think I was
given a talk at Princeton oh yeah that's
right symplectic integration ok so I'm
going to tell you that symplectic
integration does work here it's not
exactly Nesterov and that's kind of
getting back to nahdi's question that
Nesterov is in some sense blending a
gradient method and a momentum method
alright but let's proceed along I've now
told we did so we did find a
discretization which worked and here it
here's the original equation that had a
Z and an X and what we're doing is a
variable augmentation where we're
putting in a Y as well here all right
answer we get three equations out of the
two and we ask that this Y's satisfy a
certain condition and here is the
condition if you're familiar with it
sort of Nesterov style stuff this is not
surprising in kind of a dual norm on the
gradient this is kind of a you know a
relative size of this inner product
relative to its dual norm of its
gradient so if if Y were to satisfy that
sufficient condition then we have a
theorem that says that this
discretization actually achieves the
fast rate in discrete time so it's
stable and it achieves the 1 over K to
the P not P to the minus 1 slow
right okay and this theorem was proved
in the original paper with Asia and Rey
and then Asia has subsequently developed
a whole technology of taking a
continuous time Li upon a function and
turn the NN to a discrete time we open
our function so by passing estimate
sequences all together and just working
with the Alpen off theory both in
containers in sweet time so she's able a
new theory to get this theorem in a much
more slick way and do that for a bunch
of other problems okay so that you know
is a disk rotation but now how do we
achieve this sufficient condition and
again if you know the kind of nestra of
literature you know how to do that
you run the primal algorithm so you
interlace that step that we had before
from euler discretization with this step
we have from all disk relation with this
thing which is just kind of the proximal
algorithm you know based on the
approximation to F and a regularizer
okay so this thing here if you just ran
it all by itself would have the slow
rate okay but you nest it inside these
two steps this thing achieves that
sufficient condition we had on the
previous page so that's three equations
together give you the fast rate so
people have kind of noticed this there's
some papers on kind of the syntax of
nest Rawls message they're kind of be a
nesting of a kind of a convex
combination and a mirror descent method
and a and a proxy method but that's just
syntax that's not explanatory and so you
know you can think about this now as a
discretization method you can start to
discretize these equations in general
with this approach alright so I've just
written it down for the setting where
we're looking at these different values
of P but in general you can use this
framework so you sing it for her piece
you get Newton's with it but they know
I'm not saying for higher piece you get
Newton's method
oh no you get you get cubic and
constraint a regular eyes Newton not
Newton's method this is just history
information because you're oh yeah no
you have to use so to beat to get one
over T to the cubed which we can get and
then one over K cubed we obviously are
beating the Oracle rate
because we are using F of P minus 1 is
the higher approximation F so we're
making more assumptions we're assuming
that F is not not just smooth but it has
the gradient of smooth or the or the has
seen is smooth we're going up this
hierarchy of smoothness as you make more
assumptions you can get faster rates in
the auricle rate and we're achieving
that Oracle rate no no we're we're
allowing ourselves now have we're doing
cubic where you guys Newton for example
so that the Oracle allows you to have
access to higher higher derivatives this
is clear where it comes up the equation
because the equation of the gradient to
fit the in every eye does it involves
this is the Taylor expansion up to order
P minus 1 of the function yeah
no no okay so just summarize what we've
done so far is that we have taken kind
of where the literature has been in
discrete time
which you know classically we got
algorithms which had this slow rate but
they were natural algorithms and you
know this we didn't do this but this is
known that you can think of about the
mecca dinners time they are gradient
flows and there's kind of a general form
of gradient flow where you take the
gradient and you normalize it by a
particular dual norm and you can get
these rates where P gets larger and
larger larger but these are the slow
rates and then what Nesterov has done is
to move us over to this part of the
diagram here he showed how to take
radient based methods and accelerate
them and get this to be P not P to the
minus 1 and what we've done is to say
that well underlying the Nesterov
approach in continuous-time there's also
a way of thinking about this in
generality and it's this Lagrangian
approach alright so we get the fast
rates in continuous time slow rates fast
slow okay so the that's where we are so
far and now let's return this symplectic
integration idea somehow this is all
about integration and and how to
integrate integrate in a quick way so
let's talk about that so let's just look
at gradient flow for a minute here is
the gradient flow equation if you
initialize close enough to the optimum
this is a good algorithm but if you're
far from the optimal gradient flow is
too slow
how do you fix that well there are
assistive physical systems that we've
just shown in the previous part of the
talk that take a lagrangian and they
write this out as a pair of force order
equations and they can get quicker into
the neighborhood right but once you're
in the neighborhood all this momentum
they're building up it hurts you because
it makes you oscillate too much and you
don't converge into the answer like
gradient flow does all right so let's
see this this is just integrating the
differential equations this is doing it
with a select ik integrator and you can
sort of see that it takes kind of big
steps and there's a lot of oscillation
and it's slowing you down as you start
to get towards the optimum okay so you
know question the interesting question
and I think is to put these two together
all right so if you just do that you
just kind of glue the two together add
them together literally the the momentum
things we've been looking at so far if
you symplectic integrate them they're
nice and stable they look you know they
they meet I have a net here's the worst
case rate but if you add the gradient
thing in and you get a algorithm which
also has the same worst-case rate but in
practice is actually going faster okay
so it's important to note that this
discretization is really important if
you turn the step size up too much this
thing becomes unstable if you have too
small of a step size of course you slow
yourself down quite a bit especially
early on and you want to find you want
to be able to use large step sizes okay
so to do this we want to move from a
Lagrangian formulation to a Hamiltonian
formulation and this is just because we
know that the physicists tell us this is
the better way to get actual
differential equation solvers that can
move quickly and have more robust stable
properties so you take these two
variables here the position and the
velocity you do a Finchel transform on
the velocity to get the momentum
literally just the usual Finchel
transform you're used to it's called a
Legendre transform in physics and that
gives you Q and P now these are
non-homogeneous and that's fine for
Lagrangian the third time very nothing
changes it's just this total derivative
but when you go to the Hamiltonian
formulation formulation
you know time-variant hamiltonians are
not typical you want the hamiltonian be
fixed and you get limit cycles so but
there's a way to handle that which is
that you introduce now a explicit time
variable and its conjugate is the energy
so you take this time variable put it in
as a explicit variable in your phase
space you conjugate it and get the
energy so now you get these four values
to define your phase space and your
dynamics now goes from these pair of
derivatives to this set of berries
either the classical Hamiltonian and
these are the two new derivatives you
get to complete the system and get
yourself a total constant Lagrangian
defined on a well-defined phase space ya
Finchel conjugacy yeah yeah for time and
energy that's right okay so I did not
write down the Hamiltonian here but I
can just say it it's the bregman
divergence plus the the VF getting set
of - okay the bregman versus the
arguments change a little bit - but
basically it's just like in physics you
go from minus to plus all right and now
with the Hamiltonian usually you just
write down Hamilton's equation the
derivative of the hamiltonian Specter P
derivative Hamiltonian circuit Q set
them equal to zero and solve we're also
adding the T and the energy as well long
story short so you can get out the same
differential equations we've been
getting out with a Hamiltonian
perspective as you get with a bronzy and
but now the integration methodology is
different you can pick up the book my
favorite book is by hair at all
it's called geometric functional
analysis that's where I forget the word
anyway you can take this Hamiltonian out
and throw it into that machinery of
symplectic integration and you get these
fast algorithms so here is a step size
at 1.125 on our particular problem this
is kind of a banana shape here is the
Lagrangian a grater boom that goes off
to infinity that's too big of a step
size for it with that same step size we
get a very very stable beautiful
symplectic integrator okay so if you now
add in you take that symplectic
integrator and you add in gradient
descent you get an algorithm okay
it's now currently met motivated sort of
ad-hoc we're just taking two things
we're putting them together but we do
get an algorithm here which is this
thing right here which is beating Nestor
off okay so it's basically the same it
looks different for Nesterov there's
similarities it's not the same exact
algorithm but it has captured the spirit
of Nestor off okay which is that it's
able to make fast progress early on and
then it's also later on able to dive
into the optimum okay so I'm going to
stop here we're still kind of working on
this the early on I thought that the
following statement was true Nesterov is
just symplectic integration okay I
thought that's a nice discovery that's
not true Nesterov is somehow a little
more sophisticated it does this convex
combination which is not dynamics it's
kind of a rotation but Nesterov is it
seems like symplectic integration plus
gradient flow rainy descent all right
and so we're still kind of trying to
grope towards a you know a principled
way of thinking about that okay so
that's all I wanted to say about that
are there questions about that I've used
45 over my minutes yeah you can't
recover all so somebody
No we can in principle we have more
toner so yeah this framework had
absolutely applied a non-convex you know
you can write down that bregman
lagrangian and it will give rates with
ly up and off but we have a men working
on their servers it several things we
have been working on yet so i kind of
wanted to front though this in the talk
because this is just starting we haven't
worked on non-convex we have also worked
on stochastic so it's all about just
grading descent and an accelerated
gradient so it's of great interest to
talk about diffusions so take the
stochastic stuff and turn it into
differential equations and talk about
SDEs and is there optimal way to diffuse
was a question could ask alright and
there's going to be some kind of a
fokker-planck equation or something like
they're a potential theory equation
which will generate SDEs which diffuse
optimally and so I'm sure that exists
I'm sure is a parallel theory and we're
working on that too but and I just want
to invite anyone in the room to work on
that I think there's a lot of you
already contributed things like that I
think there's a lot of interest in
starting to get a more general SD kind
of perspective here let me just also
note that I before I forget that
symplectic Gallagher's have come up in
one other place in our literature and
statistics which is that they are used
in what's called hybrid Monte Carlo so
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo you take Monte
Carlo and you write down a Hamiltonian
which gives you the momentum and you
have to integrate that Hamiltonian if
you just integrated in a way it's not
that great if you integrate with
symplectic integrator the leapfrog in
here is an example of a simple ekta
Kinta greater then it's much better and
that is the best method as far as i'm
aware by far in in monte car and Markov
chain Monte Carlo so it has come up
there for kind of a good reason which is
that it is able to make very very fast
progress in the MCMC case towards the
optimum then still kind of move around
stochastically in the optimization case
we're also seeing it gets you close to
the optimum and then we'd like to dive
into the optimum at that point but
there's a obviously some parallels here
so integration is behind optimization as
well as behind Bayesian inference is
kind of the message yeah
I'm still quite upset answer the way
question so I see how the grading
descent combines of acceleration the
operators the craft itself right there's
this accelerated path did yeah by
choosing a specific tying up all these
parameters a specific way that's right
it actually doesn't matter for the path
that's right it didn't matter for the
path you take those parameters in
different ways you could have done
getting flow or you could have got other
things yeah that's right you would have
lost the fast rate so we were using that
as our guide for how to tie them a way
to think about how to I mean it seemed
that you it seemed to me to me maybe
explains that you tighten these things
in a way using milling what the answer
should be if I would didn't know but on
this reservation they had there was four
parameters yeah and I kind to understand
their space of possible things and so
liberation front of what is the best
thing to do what would even guide me
because you know that is he said I can
see that from the camping you're asking
all the right exact questions that we've
been asking and so the early decision
was is that these things should be tied
to get the fast train in continuous time
everything should flow from that and
everything sort of flowed for that but
didn't quite we got these nice and
plaiting editors they did really well
except Nesterov would beat us at the end
so we've glued on yeah you're right that
space we have now it's not explored the
alpha beta and gamma is gives us a
richer space we thought this part of
space was the only important part but
it's a richer part and we could recover
other algorithms or by exploring that oh
now we're motivated too because we
realize that that part of space was very
interesting for the first part of
optimization but not for the end all
right let me move yeah quick but rates
don't depend on H that's right the new
the numbers the the constants certainly
do yeah it's just the our usual oriented
mirror descending and gradient you know
it's really I think of it more as a
modeling issue that it's the geometry
that you want to be on so it's kind of
apples and oranges okay let me talk
about the second part just I think I've
got ten minutes and so I'm going to do
five minutes on each of two little
topics these are unrelated what we've
talked about but I wanted in this crowd
to kind of mention ongoing work my group
so chichen is may be here but he's
around and then a bunch of other
collaborators
in the world so this is about avoiding
saddle points and doing it efficiently
efficient here means yeah get in good
dimension dependence okay so we really
got to worry about dementia in this
particular line of work so this is still
gradient descent and we're going to make
some assumptions so we talked about
avoiding saddle points okay so is
voiding set of points important well
yeah it's you know I remember when I
really was running neural network
simulators back early Heidi's got Dave
Rommel hearts original back prop code
and I was working with it on a bunch of
problems and I remember how it would
come down real fast into a plateau and
then would come down fast into a plateau
and I do that like three times in
arrived at the optimum and the optin was
really quite impressive
I just nerd this to this day and I think
people are still seeing that and what
those plateaus are or saddle points all
right so it's spending a fair amount of
time near a saddle point but if it's
spent too much time near a saddle point
then you would think your converged
alright
so it's really important not spend too
much time here the saddle points so on
the optimization side that's really
important and of course outside of
neural nets there's a bunch of other
problems tensor completion is the most
studied one where it's kind of clear
there's a global it's known there's a
global optimum there's kind of a ring of
saddle points around it and whole
problems to get past them quickly and
get to global Optima okay so to set up
some structure to talk about that the
usual assumption is that for gradient
descent is that you just have a
first-order stationary point and the
usual gradient rate is a set there's
kind of a Lipschitz constant and it goes
as one over epsilon squared iterations
in the non convex setting so the number
of iterations for getting ascent is
dimension free and that we all know
that's the beautiful fact about gradient
descent which is the main reason in some
sense that motivates us to pursue it for
all of our high dimensional problems
it's independent of dimensionality
alright so in general we have local mins
maxes and we have saddle points so we're
going to analyze a algorithm which is
nearly gradient descent so you it to
avoid saddle points one way to do it is
to actually allow yourself a hessian
everywhere if you have a hessian
everywhere you can see all the
directions of curvature and you can move
out of us out a point easily
algorithmically easily but that requires
a Hessian is it possible you can still
move past the gradients
the saddle points quickly even if you're
just using gradients that was the that's
this line of work so we were analyzing a
very simple situation we're just doing
gradient set but occasionally we allow
ourselves a perturbation which is
uniform in some ball of radius R and
we're going to then talk about the
theory of how to pick R and ask how fast
can perturb gradients sent with this to
one stochastic per grab a ssin which is
done occasionally as a function of the
norm of the gradient
I'll talk about that in a second okay so
to analyze this we need to have you know
what the opposition literature does is
to add a little bit more conditions
there's a notion of a secondary station
point where you have the same conditions
before but you also have that the
minimum eigen value of the Hessian is
not too negative and that you also make
a smoothness assumption on the hessian
if you didn't have that the Hessian
could vary widely over a neighborhood
you just have no hope so the hat seen is
is assumed to move and in a Lipschitz
way around the neighborhood all right
and we have a theorem which says that
this perturbed gradient descent does
converge it converges to these station
secondary stationary points so it misses
the saddle points alright and it does so
in a number of iteration which is again
in 1 over epsilon score so it goes as
fast as gradient ascent despite there
being saddle points okay that tilde
there heids dimension dependence and it
turns out that that dimension pendens is
poly logarithmic all right so I'm going
to summarize that on this slide here so
there is an existing set of work that
just looks at grading Oracle's an
existing set that looks at Hessian
Oracle's and an existing interesting set
that looks somehow in between allows you
to have your Oracle tell you a Hessian
vector product but not a full Hessian
okay and so we existing work by the same
kind of collection of authors was able
to show that this convergence rate was
poly-r algorithmic in that ratio but
this new work is is showing that it's 1
over epsilon squared so this was not as
favorable in terms of epsilon wasn't
looking like gradient descent this shows
it really is like reading a sent and
this intermediate work here showed that
it was 1 over Epsilon
and moreover had a seeming polynomial
depends in dimension which would be a
killer all right but this work is now
showing that it's actually poly
logarithmic into
mention which is shows that it's
competitive let's go to work at high
dimensions is that for real well this
was a fairly tedious analysis and that
to get that for with some work but that
for surely could be brought down I don't
know if it's all the way to one but it
can probably be brought down I do want
to mention this work here of John du
cheese at Stanford Stanford and his
colleagues and others have been also
getting these rates of 1 over epsilon
squared and logarithmic defensive
dimensions so very similar with this
extra Oracle alright and I it's it now
there'll be an interesting debate
between these two things this is a
little more complicated for like
backpropagation can get these things
relatively cheaply or you can
numerically difference that'll add extra
errors you have to analyze and so on so
it'll be an ongoing thing about whether
this is real you can really get this
I suspect the literature might fold back
to this because in my experience of 30
years the literature always goes for the
simplest possible thing and showing that
this little perturbation on gradient
gets past a low points is perhaps enough
motivation there's a bit of differential
geometry and analysis here and we just
point you in the paper there is a little
new differential geometry here that
there's analysis of a so called we call
a stuck region around a saddle point
that generically all saddle points have
it such that if you are in the stuck
region with this little perturbation if
it with some probability will get you
out of the stuck region and if you're
out with high probability the flow will
get you out completely the the power
method will get you out all right and we
analyzed those probabilities ok the
function of the geometry ok yeah we
don't know it doesn't we don't have a
lower bound kind of here but so this is
a sufficient condition this just this
perturbation switch gets you this one
could analyze other forms of
perturbation one can analyze no
perturbation at all but we don't know
that currently doesn't I do not believe
it does but you know because this
argument is generic and I you know great
innocent I think will generically get in
there but I it's not in the proof yeah
there's this uh sort of
folk wisdom then non-convex optimization
for deep learning that the acid SGD
helps and this would seem to add
supports to that this is related I mean
so we're not doing the SNS G D which
would have stochasticity natural is part
of the problem on every step we're
adding it in a particular way when the
grade it gets small we added and we
don't add it once we've added it we wait
a little while to add it again so it's a
particularly at that has to do with this
geometry but there is an ongoing we're
working now on the SGD formulation and
just natural s G you can achieve the SGD
good rate even if they're saddle points
just with native ace s UD alright last
couple of minutes let me just mention
some of the work of Li hua who's here on
stochastic Li controlled stochastic
gradient so now we are actually going to
SGD kind of algorithms and i hope you
all know about this line of work I think
Francie Spock was one of the people who
originated it but analyzing this
particular kind of loss function which
is a sum over your data and not just a
general convex function you know
Lipschitz and strongly convex conditions
or non strongly convex if u is equal to
zero and our Oracle is just one unit of
cost for gradients and for function
values kind of the usual set up and
there's this SVR G algorithm that kind
of saga is another example of this that
you know have these favorable rates in
terms of epsilon but have that that n
sitting there that's you know if n is a
billion this is a killer okay and so the
problem with these algorithms is that we
need write down show you if you don't
know s GPR G here's SVR G so Johnson and
Shang so what they do is they do
gradient ascent here you take your
current gradient you subtract off
something which involves the globally
computed gradient calculate every once
in a while so this is one epic one
iteration with an inner loop here and
what you do is you compute a full
gradient over the entire dataset there's
where you pay your in cost all right and
they use it as a control okay you then
take the perturbation author your
gradient off of that as a way to get the
variance down all right so you prove
that this is has a good rate and it so
it's using the stochastic effectively
but controlling
okay but the computational cost is too
high because you have to take this
gradient every once awhile so the
natural question ask is what if you take
a stochastic gradient here so you don't
take the entire data set you take a
small subset of the data to use as your
your reference gradient and you plug
that in here well that'll give you extra
you'll lose some variance control but
you'll get a computational gain can you
control all of that and still get a fast
rate and the answer is yes
so just reminding you of some of the
rates that you get here for general
convex and strongly convex the things
we've just been seen have these fast
raises in terms of epsilon so it turns
things around if you set T for this you
get episode 1 over T squared here you
get 1 over square root of T so there's
your rates for classical gradients and
here are rates for the stochastic case
here's SGD this is this new algorithm
called stochastic lis controlled
stochastic radio show it to you on the
next slide
it does take this smaller batch size and
it is like SGD this is minimum so
eventually this term will not matter it
is also 1 over epsilon squared okay so
these other algorithms that so this
algorithm gets rid of the N dependence
all right and still be despite the extra
stochastic achieves the rate the
favorable rate of SGD okay
there is a fancier version of this
algorithm I should say on the strongly
convex case as well it achieves these
though the linear convergence of SGD
again with this factor going away and so
it's basically the same as SGD right
this algorithm here is actually beating
the Oracle rate this is actually going
away log n over N so it's actually going
down not at one of us on square but 1
over epsilon right and what's happening
is that this is actually an average case
analysis it's not a worst case analysis
so it's actually able to beat the Oracle
let me show you what this algorithm is
it's very simple it takes the SVR G
template and instead of taking the full
gradient it randomly picks the gradient
a batch of data of size B or B is
relatively small it computes it's
stochastic gradient based on that and it
uses that as the baseline down here
moreover it is important that it uses a
random variable here it takes that the
number of inner loop iterations to be
geometrically distributed with a
particular choice of gamma so that's
actually important in the in the proof
and in the algorithm so you do this
geometric number of iterations and do
step casting radius in that so it's a
pretty simple template pretty easy to
run on two parallel eyes and so that's
what that does so there's two versions
of this thing one of them just fixes
these batch sizes the other one makes
them increase according to a factor okay
I think that's what I wanted to say and
I am now done yeah
you need to go back to the slides
yeah here yeah so it seems like to get
rid of the independents you need to
choose epsilon V at least whatever
enters yeah and you want to jump in by
the way Li hua though but yeah that
weird this is an algorithm which is good
kind of when epsilon is not you're not
too aggressive with epsilon so when n is
really really big thank a terabyte you
know one over N is really really tiny
and being bigger than that for epsilon
is very very natural all right so these
analyses where epsilon is much much
smaller than one over N is just not very
interesting and some of these analysis
that's the raging they focus on but I
consider as a statistician that's just
not the interesting regime I don't know
if you want to add to that that's good
yeah you think this is big circle savage
case but it is we have the average case
or the lower bounds here which are tight
waiting in combination of just eaters to
castigating sent or accelerated SPG yes
do you want to jump in we were just talk
about this and yeah step arms and
doesn't fall into any framework of
existing lower point work suits in the
sense that it almost all existing
framework they need somehow the iterates
xk q to me some markovia no that's not
so we have been analysis i think you
know you see that we have analysis which
is for any just a straightforward oracle
analysis for an average for lower bound
for an average case of it so it doesn't
data rates on it to be anything it's
just an oracle or about that but you you
need some how oddly oblivious or
something like that but here since
there's underlying poisson process so a
big is twist
well it's just a lower bound it's just
all of our numbers oracle accesses
information
go you don't have any assumption why
don't we take this one off line this is
a great good discussion but yes there's
a important question about what you mean
by an Oracle in the average case and
that's yes Nadia's contributed that but
it's there's a love some still some
debate yeah is there anything else all
right
[Applause]